rando pays vous emmène cette semaine à
cilaos pour une petite randonnée
accessible à tous le sentier des sources
au dessus du village de bras sec
à cilaos direction bras sec
après avoir des mains faibles
grissom et rial
les régions se parent qui demain
rando pays vous propose cette semaine
une randonnée dans le cirque de cilaos
aurait mon coach en tête sur l'arête des
trois salades fréquenté de cilaos
rendez-vous à cilaos prendre la route en
direction un deal est encore après 5
kilomètres regardez au départ mais
chantier marc la lépi duteil les
directions de bras sec
cette randonnée que nous effectuons en
compagnie de jérôme turpin 2ème réunion
ces manceaux le chantier bat et c'est
une grand clasico side avec laroche
merveilleux la montée du bloc
difficulté de ce sentier en effet c'est
là leur première teinture sur l'ensemble
d'ailleurs ou avec un sens très large et
de grosse marche bien taillé à l'ombre
du grand parler fort passe tout seul
sinon les boss sont les bienvenus pour
en apprendre un peu plus sur cette
espèce endémique
passer la sauce jacquod c'est la levée
ali d'être les salages reconnaissable à
sa cabane célèbre pour ses tisanes
ascension a longtemps compté blanc au
dessus de cette île est la vue se dégage
seul aussi depuis deux ans un important
travail de danse richement a été
entrepris ce qui nous permet
d'appréhender facilement aux lacets du
parcours et où on va emprunter la
bifurcation qui a cinq minutes la
justice nous on va passer juste au
niveau d'aidé y aller tu ce qu'on va
facilement des partisans végétation et
ensuite on verra langois bien que la
dernière par ici ce sera la partie la
plus la plus raide pour arriver au
sauver c'est bien praticable
c'est là en bon c'est vrai qu'avec
l'impression que tu ne sois à l'aise et
bien quitté ce parti c'est de sédières
trakya cam les éboulis sont fréquents ce
sentier faut savoir qu'il a été coupé
par un éboulis là qui n'est pas qui
n'est pas très loin à l'intersection la
croisée ou qui te senti du tales une kia
lui furent caisson laurent par des
salazes en direction de ce secteur
collet vient ensuite la traversée d'un
agréable plateau parsemé d'espèces
exotiques comme l'eucalyptus
donc c'est surtout de nombreuses espèces
pays tels que les brandes élima aux
découvertes par de saint-antoine
le sentier le long du passage de km en
d'oise
on est sur une
leiria là au dessus des lettres des
salazes c'était un ancien pâturages où
les gens de le sentier côtier de la
direction par lundi ce massage sur un
autre mettre au point de vue sur une
partie du village dans l'idée de ce jeu
c'est le poney de près a réuni domi en
fait c'était l'abri des anciens des
anciens c'est l'abandon
saoulé cryptomérias l'ambiance change du
tout au tout
avec la pente qui se renforce de
l'ensica steger talent mais la lumière
c'est cette journée pour pouvoir y est
les efforts comme au bout d'une petite
redescendre vers allemands se sentent
chansons de la population sur la toile a
été replanté
oui magique après avoir quitté le
sentier qui mène vers cabotage c'est
maintenant l'ascension du col choupette
c'est la dernière partie de cette
randonnée qui est aussi la plus
technique ou détruits ont tout cassé
dans ce secteur il faut parfois c'est le
dénommé se méfier des racines véritable
décor est planté
le mot enfin on atteint le coach ou fait
seul arrêté trois salazes changer quand
le spectacle se joue ici à 360° en aussi
un grand bénare mafate le piton des
neiges qu'avait autrefois le secteur de
broissia
certainement l'un des plus beaux
panoramas de 10
quelques passes et l'arrivée à bras sec
au niveau du stade
la route est juste là il faudra la roue
tourne et je prie pour nous et notre
point de débat et qu'on arrive ici on
est directement et bayous pas le point
de vue se sentent menacés quand j'aime
avec mafate
c'est déjà la consigne et d'espèces
endémiques qui trouve ce que j'aime bien
c'est le bras louches et avec lola rouge
lao avec ses figures imposant la d1 sont
chiés les plus fréquentes et les plus
comme des moutons
si l'os ce que j'aime aussi sur ce
sentier est celle c'est les points de
vue calme qu'on arrive dès qu'on a fini
le sentir un super point de vue sur
cilaos et le village de bras sec le
bonnet pendant la sortie concours facile
kokoïty bandeau sur écoutes les gens et
dimanche appris lundi la pana le fait un
petit plateau si les enfants mettant dos
à gaza les plantes endémiques de la
réunion
oui ils peuvent faire ce essentielle
c'est accessible à tout le monde prenne
ou les très courts mais d'une hausse de
7 à 77 ans et on se soucie plus que
j'aime ce sentiment là notamment avec
ses fils damian qui donne des radiations
quand il commence à marcher c'est hyper
glissante faudra être extrêmement sur
ses racines de culte aux médias son
hyperviseur que ça fait si on fait pas
attention non leur s invitent à la
renverse sont impures